90% of scripts are rejected by the
industry after the first scene yeah so
what are screenwriters doing wrong and
what was like what's so horrible about
what's so terrible about these
scenes yeah so when I was a studio
reader so when I was in film school was
a crazy dream to be a writer I was
working as a studio reader and what we
were trained is read the first two scene
let me step back if a script came in by
the Coen brothers or Quentin Tarantino
you you're reading that whole script and
if you don't like it you're reading it
again to see what's wrong with you and
then you're calling your friends who
read it like you taking this very
seriously because you giving them
extreme benefit of the doubt but I was
taught when your rhiness script by some
an unknown writer a new writer read the
first two scenes and stop and ask
yourself do I have to keep reading and
yet the answer is no then don't I have a
lot of students who are readers now and
they do they have the one scene I guess
you know tensions fans have shrunken
with Twitter and everything so they read
one scene I think here's what I would
say if I read a scene of a script and it
doesn't absolutely make me want to read
the next scene I know this writer is not
going to be successful script why it's
not going to get better if you if you
your first scene is like your interviews
if someone goes to a job interview for a
job they really want they're late
they're disheveled they reek of alcohol
they're doing inappropriate jokes
they're just doing everything wrong
right you're interviewing this person
you're like okay this is this person on
their best behavior gonna be like on a
bad or you know you go on a first date
as person is a disaster like this is
them on their best behavior
yeah your first scene is if you know
anything about writing it's your first
impression that is you on your best
behavior oh I like that so if your first
scene it doesn't have conflict just
something I believe I talked about in a
previous film courage video otherwise
there's a lot on my site about that or
the characters
don't feel like compelling characters or
it's supposed to be funny but it's not
like all the stuff we were talking about
you know in terms of what you're selling
with a pilot script now I'm not looking
for an engine I don't need to have the
concept but it bet you better nail the
genre and and the characters better be
characters I absolutely want to spend
time with and you better know how to
write in compelling conflict now let's
say someone can do all of that that
doesn't mean that the whole script is
going to be great it means it might and
you know one of the things and by the
way I really would recommend for anyone
who's serious about being a writer if
possible try to go on the other side of
the fence for six months try to be a
reader someone who evaluates scripts for
six months you can do it for that for
the like the writing competitions but if
possible especially if you live in LA I
would try to do it for an agency a
management company a production company
producer someone who's in the industry
someone was involved with buying of
projects and I always tell people do it
for six months but not a day longer
because you'll lose yourself and I don't
mean that what I mean is most people
most writers who start down that path if
they stay on that path too long they end
up becoming executives or producers and
they stop writing and and maybe they're
happier for that but I think six months
is a great time to learn what it's like
to be on the other side of the fence
because as a writer your job is to write
scripts that total strangers will read
and fall so in love with that they're
willing to go to their boss and go to
bat for you and you know I'll put it an
even more important way when I was
starting out I thought the key was I had
to get a manager and then an agent I had
to get people who were out there
advocating for me because I can't do
that you know as an unknown writer I
can't call up horner brothers or Netflix
and say hey you don't know me but I
wrote a script and it's great you can't
first of all they're not going to take
your call right and good luck getting
through yeah
good luck if you do yeah right so I
thought I needed two people or at least
one person out there advocating for me
if you're really smart
that's not your objective your objective
is to get an army of people advocating
for you and the way to do that goes back
to writing pitch perfect authentic
scripts which I talked about in the
previous film courage videos check those
out if you haven't seen this because
when you write something that's unique
non formulaic with amazing characters an
engine an amazing concept people who
read it and I was one of those people
and I have a lot of students who are
these people they will to this a very
small community Hollywood and they will
email or call or text people and say
have you read Karen's script have you
read this script and they're like no and
they're like you should and they send
the script it's called the script
travels well the script goes viral and
within days everyone's has read it and
everyone wants to meet you know who you
are
because your script has gone and
everyone's buzzing about it so when
you're writing a script the the so I'm
sorry I'm going a little bit off tangent
here but I will bring it all together in
a moment so when I first thing I do in
my UCLA class because they're so overly
educated they don't realize what a
liability that is so what I'll say is
your writing I could do it with a
feature or a TV TV script 60 minutes
what has to happen let's say there's
four scenes in act 1 what has to happen
in that last scene what's the objective
of that scene and I get incredibly smart
answers you know it's the point of no
return it's the first crisis it's the
it's the first subplot it's the reverse
I mean I get all these really smart
answers they're all wrong but they're
really smart the answer is the fourth
scene what it must do is get total
strangers to have to read the fifth C
and the fifth scene has to get read the
sixth it's true of every scene every
scene has to compel someone to read the
next scene and so that first scene has
to get someone to read the second scene
think about the first scene as a
versity you're not getting married on
that date they're not buying your script
the job of a first date is to get a
second date job of a second date to get
a third date now enough dates in a row
and then someone will be like okay like
I want to get in a relationship with you
that's the moment when they're like I
will read your whole script they'll come
a point where someone will become such a
fan because they'll realize here's the
concept I know where this is going and I
think that's an awesome idea for a show
or a movie love these characters and and
these scenes are structured so tightly
and in such a compelling way I'm
starting to get confidence that this
person knows how to structure and at
some point you're like I will read this
to the end and then when you get to the
end your job is fitting the fall in love
and when they fall in love that's when
they will tell everyone about your
script it's like you're watching a TV
show that you love and no one else is
watching it you're telling all your
friends oh you've got to watch the show
you got to watch the show we do that
with scripts so that's your job so now
that that statistic of 98% sometimes
people get mad at me and and or they
want to debate that number so just to be
clear that's not my number I didn't come
up here if you're upset don't direct it
at me I am just the messenger
it's very simple I've been teaching at
UCLA since 2007 I have brought in
countless executives producers agents
managers I always ask these people the
gatekeepers when you get a script from a
writer that's not a current client and
not an established write or a new writer
how long do you read then decide if
you're gonna keep reading and they
always say one or two scenes I have
heard people say the first 10 pages they
were in a good mood but is usually one
or two scenes I asked those people what
percentage of the time do you keep
reading and I have heard 1% 2% far less
than 1% and it probably averages out to
about 1% but I tried to be a little more
optimistic and I may
two percent so when I say 98% of non
establish writers if they move mountains
to get their script into the marketplace
90 percent of the time people stopped
reading after one or two scenes that is
solely based on what all these producers
agents and managers and what my
experience was many years ago as a
reader so anyone who takes offense or
son like that number I didn't come up
with it I am the messenger sure and and
then I I will when I teach I'll say how
many of you right now are executives or
readers or story and listen there's
usually like six or seven hands that go
up and I go so let me ask you when I say
only 2% of scripts are continued to be
read after the first scene or two do you
think that's accurate do you think
that's too generous you think that's too
pessimistic and across the board they'll
say you're being way too generous you're
protecting these people it's less than
2%
oh so that's what these people are
saying and why is sometimes being too
smart getting in your own way
yeah because what happens is they learn
all these rules so the industry has
changed so the industry has dramatically
changed so it used to be that there were
three or four channels and basically
what everyone was doing there's Donald
Glover had a great interview on The New
Yorker about this the brilliant creator
and star of atlantis.oh
back in the day like up to I don't know
2000 2002 whatever you have three or
four networks and that was it and they
were making macaroni and cheese they
were making comfort food you come home
after a long day and you want a drama
you want a comedy you want a spiritual
whatever and they would follow paradigms
so all the comedies were the same
structure different jokes and the crime
scenes you know CSI Hollywood CSI
Missouri CSI Australia
same structure just different crime and
the idea was we're creating comfort food
and what we're gonna do is put a star
that you like you like Ted Danson we're
gonna do
a pony and cheese would you like hello
yeah LM generous we're gonna do macaroni
and cheese with Ellen generous and the
truth is these shows were designed to
get the widest audience possible ratings
for advertising so they wanted two shows
to be watched by as many people as
possible so you wanna show doesn't
offend people you want to show that a
lot of people like and the truth is
people would watch a show and they're
like it's okay it's not great but they
don't change the channel
because they know there's nothing better
in the other two or three channels and
this says Ted Danson and I like Ted
Danson so I'll just stick with this
that's how it used to be and now there's
so much content that we know because we
have metadata that people sample pilots
and then it's like they're on a date for
10 minutes they're like well who else
can I date and they're just jumping and
what in most cases not all cases but in
most cases what determines success or
failure is follow-through simple simply
put what percentage of the people who
watch the first episode watch all the
episodes
that's follow-through because in a world
of too much content what you need is
brand loyalty you need people that'll
stick with your show so girls I think
had about two million people watching it
that's not a large aggregate number but
I think it had one of the highest if not
the highest follow through well over 90
something percent of people who watch
the first episode of girls they watched
every episode of girls that's valuable
now because it used to be again largest
number possible and also to have a lot
of episodes to put it into syndication
very few shows go to syndication there's
just so much original content so it's
all about creating shows that in a world
of too much content people are going to
stick with this show and so you see that
a lot of the scripts that are being
bought they're not the paradigm driven
rule driven script anymore they used to
be like if you go back 15 years ago
you're an unknown writer that's what
you'd want to write if you wanted to
sell something nowadays as my agent well
my former agent we don't have agents
right now but my former agent W
has repeatedly said if you're doing a
three camera standard paradigm driven
comedy or paradigm driven procedural
unless you've been an executive producer
or above in a hit show in that space in
the last three years your scripts do a
no one's gonna read it what you need to
be doing is writing a script that no one
has seen before writing something that
only you could have written and making
an elevated story so instead of
preordained plot points the the story
unfolds organically and it's not
predictable and it feels that characters
are doing what they would really be
doing and saying what they'd really be
saying and it's captivating these are
the hardest scripts to write these are
the pitch perfect authentic scripts but
this is what the majority of scripts
that are selling these are the scripts
that are selling now there are paradigm
and rule driven scripts that sell but
they're predominantly written by people
who are executive producers or above on
those hit shows and further it used to
be if you want to get staffed on a TV
show which is generally the entry way
starting place for a TV writer to get
staffed on an existing show work your
way up the ladder you would want to
write specs of existing show so if
you're a comedy writer you would write
spec episodes of hit comedies or spec
episodes of procedurals almost no
showrunner in town would read dot script
what they will read is original scripts
they and here's why they need their show
to make an emotional connection to the
audience to get follow through they need
writers who can create emotional
attachment they want to read your script
and see that you're a magician that you
could write a script that is unique that
has characters that just I have to keep
following these characters I have to
keep reading this script that's what
they're looking for when they staff
their show I have a friend as a
showrunner I mean he has a budget from
the streaming company for nine staff
writers and you only have seven because
he can't find nine because there's so
many shows and everyone who's good is
working and they're running shows or
they're the second that's a big problem
is getting enough really amazing writers
so the people coming out of these these
programs and
a lot of time they have been trained to
fight a war that ended seven years ago
so what these institutions are teaching
was absolutely true at the time and it's
just it's a lot harder for a big
institution to sort of change course for
a lot of reasons so anyway I'm not
venomous a from UCLA I love the
experience I mean a lot of great
connections a lot of great friends but
but to answer your question I I find a
lot of I have a lot of agents and
managers send me writers to work with in
my workshops because they're overly
educated they know all the rules I know
all the paradigms their heads full of
what you can do or can't do it's
ridiculous when you see what is selling
when you see what showrunners are
looking for they're looking for
something that is absolutely original
and captivating they don't want the
rules they don't want the paradigms
they don't that's that's easy they want
someone who could create something that
people is memorable it's impactful that
you have an emotional attachment to
because they need to create shows that
when someone watches it they will keep
watching that show so almost as if
you're talking about the marvelous
missus myzel
Mazal myzel sorry it she's it's almost
that kind of that metaphor of she was
the perfect
whatever friend mother everything is
overly sanitized perfect but nobody
wants to watch that they want to see
somebody who's gonna really like like
push the envelope and offend people
possibly maybe not but but really like
go outside the lines yes that's really
the same thing with the writers it
sounds like yes that's really smart and
if we want to use more of us miss might
as well we can go a little bit deeper as
a metaphor because I think it was a
brilliant metaphor in that show for
writers so we have a character who
doesn't want to get rejected so I mean
as a wife she's taken sex classes to be
perfect in bed this is in the show she
not only have her makeup on perfectly in
her hair when she goes to bed she wakes
up an hour earlier oh wow Rhee does her
makeup and hair gargles with mouthwash
pretends to be asleep so when the alarm
goes
and her husband wakes up she is a angel
she's the perfect daughter she's the
perfect I mean she's so charming and
she's so wonderful but it comes from
this terrible terrible fear of being
rejected so you already know as creating
the show she's gonna get rejected a lot
by her husband and by society and
her parents but to the metaphor I would
say then this I can relate to this as a
writer it was one of my biggest
struggles and I never overcame it and as
part of why I stopped writing and I see
a lot of writers with this struggle if
you are so afraid of rejection then it
makes you or it can compel you to be the
kind of person that you think people
want you to be and this could be true as
a son or a daughter or a spouse or a
writer so you start writing in a way
that you think is what people are
looking for and you're scared of writing
in a way that could offend people and so
people who are so terrified of rejection
can become the kind of person who it's
hard to reject but the person they
become is not who they really are so the
fear of rejection can lead people to
reject themselves so afraid of being
rejected you reject who you truly are in
the marvelous MS myzel she has gone
through her whole life being a perfect
person at the end of that pilot she's
going to been the worst thing of her
life as her husband not only is he
reject her but who we rejected her for
and when he did it and she's drunk I
managed I've it's fine but she is drunk
and gets on stage and for the first time
ever that character starts to search for
and to express her truth not as a
stand-up just because she's drunk and
she does and then Susie tells her you
are amazing you know this town as the
show unfolds what's fascinating is the
character exists in two spheres her
everyday normal sphere where she is a
perfect person and then a sphere where
she will continue to find and speak her
truth and that is on stage and really
the metaphor of the show that I take
is the only way to reach your full
potential as a creative person well this
would be true of anyone but let's stay
focused with rioters the only way to
reach your true potential is to express
who you really are through your writing
to be completely authentic and and know
that people will reject that and be okay
with that you have to be willing to be
rejected to be authentic and I know
because I spent a decade as the studio
writer never being authentic in my
writing and I wouldn't take any script
that was close to who I was and my agent
was repeatedly saying like you need to
spec something from your heart and I
would never do that because I was so
terrified of being rejected I knew at
least if I wrote a script that wasn't me
I didn't put myself into it if it got
rejected then my skill set my talent was
being rejected
I was terrifying to me but at least I
wasn't being rejected I've I was
authentic in my writing as I as I knew I
should be and I was rejected that was
just too terrifying so you know this is
film courage courage is so important and
I lacked it as a writer and that's part
of why I teach because I really want to
do what I can to help inspire other
people to not make that mistake and so I
think the marvelous is miles is a really
beautiful metaphor and to really hit
your full potential you have to be okay
with being rejected and what will happen
is you will there were people who read
the pilot or they heard they did for
Seinfeld or you know catastrophe or
Breaking Bad or orange is the new black
Russian doll hated it
I I was once the some of your viewers
might be a little young to fully
appreciate this but I was at a studio
once I'm not gonna name the studio for
reasons that will become clear and I was
early for a meeting so I was walking
around and I kind of wandered in an area
I don't think
to be and there was AI there was a box
of coverage reports coverage report says
when scripts go into the studio of
people write coverage I saw a coverage
report for Ferris Bueller's Day Off the
that's represents the minutes that
studio and they looked at the coverage
this person heeded that script they said
this is the most annoying script I ever
read first of all you have a teen
character who thinks he's the smartest
person in the world and he is and he
breaks the fourth wall and he talks to
us in such a cloying superior way and
it's like yes that was the magic of them
Oh like you loved Ferris but the point
is you take any amazing project I'll
guarantee people told Quentin Tarantino
and they read pulp fiction if you move
forward with this you're going back to
the video store like this you this is
going to be a disaster of epic
proportions there are people who read
American Beauty and said this is just
stylized melodrama there's nothing here
all it when you are your authentic self
you're going to have detractors and then
you're gonna have people that are gonna
fall in love and that's all you need is
one person to fall in love and then it
can change your life all it needs is one
person to say I'm making this this is
important and I'm doing it so film
courage writer courage is have the
courage to don't feel protected by the
rules and paradigms find what you're
trying to say create authentic
characters find the concept and go for
it and just write it completely not
worrying about being rejected and there
will be people who reject the script but
then people are gonna see who you really
are and what your voice truly is and
there going to be people who love it and
that's how someone launches a career in
the current marketplace Cory you said in
the beginning I believe of the last
question that you were listening or
reading an interview with Donald Glover
yeah I'm The Hollywood Reporter I'm I
think it was the New York The New Yorker
okay he was a New Yorker magazine and it
was a in-depth look at dongil
and I was also talking about it was
lanta which if I'm correct has won more
Awards in his first two years in an e TV
show in his first two years and Donna
Glover was talking about how it used to
be where they were trying to get the
most people possible to watch a show and
now it was following these paradigms and
these tropes o people like families that
argue then come together and love each
other then people love a mystery with a
red herring and then you find out who
did it so everyone's doing the same
generic stories just with different
dialogue or different locations of
different characters but now in a world
where there's literally too much content
nobody can watch all of the shows
nobody knows all the new shows in a
world of too much content concept and
story are king yes you need great
characters but there's so many scripts
that have great characters and it's no
longer the case that just because you
have a certain star people are gonna
watch the show there's just too many
show so what he was the point he was
making is oh and there's a really great
really great funny quote I'll let I'll
let people read it so and there's a
great quote in there but basically what
he's saying is it used to be getting the
right actor you know give me a Ted
Danson was the key now it's the story in
the concept that's what differentiates
and it's it's telling a story in a
unique way
it's telling the story in the way that's
best for that story and for the
experience you want people to have so
Atlanta is brilliantly structured it's
one of the shows that have a plot
casting class and we do case studies and
teach people how to deconstruct these
shows to see how they're put together
and Atlanta is just brilliant but if you
look at any of the paradigms or the
rules that are widely taught and then
you look at the really successful shows
like Atlanta or the marvelous misses
myzel or fleabag or Russian doll and
then if you also get scripts that have
launch writers careers in the past four
years and I've done this with my UCLA
class it just
pile the scripts have people grab
whichever ones they want and then the
question is what percentage of these
scripts adhere to the rules and the
paradigms that you've been taught and
the answer ranges from none to almost
none and then people get upset well why
am i forcing a square peg in a round
hole and I don't have to exactly so the
the article that Dong Glover was talking
about the new paradigm or the new
reality of TV and how the stories have
to make an emotional connection
they can't be predictable no the reality
we know this from the meditate metadata
is that these paradigm driven shows
that's what our parents watched you know
we grew up and came of age with
on-demand video platforms and we have as
a generation watch more TV than is
probably medically advisable we know
what's a redo we know what's a reheat
and more and more our generation is not
watching those shows
you know Murder She Wrote which was a
brilliant show in its day that's what
our parents watched and so that was the
Donald Glover was making that argument
in a much more articulate way than I
just did and so you can go look at it
it's in The New Yorker two years ago or
so
you